well it is a big week around here we
have officially launched now the first
round of MO firing downrange at the
Student Loan debacle and it is time to
blow this thing up and we are in the
process of blowing it up there are
several places to blow it up the last
one will probably be the political one
because they're so stupid it takes them
a long time to catch on but a whole
bunch of you have already caught on and
realized student loans are a bad idea
they don't work it's an epic plague on
America with 1.6 trillion dollars in
student loan debt all these unintended
consequences affecting the economy
affecting people's lives and they're
trapped they're overwhelmed they don't
know what to do and Congress continues
to make the loans did you hear me
America is being harmed by its own
Congress time to stop it Congress you're
the last ones to catch on so we'll go
ahead and start with you the rest of you
out here have already caught on you
figured out smoking kills you so you
teach your kids don't smoke you figured
out smoking weed removes all ambition
from the brain so you teach your kids
don't smoke weed figured out student
loans are killing people not literally
on a few pages of cases but more extreme
but figuratively metaphorically
financially they're stealing your dreams
and the whole idea of getting education
was so that you could live your dreams
we want you to live your dreams we want
you to be smart people we want you to be
educated people but the whole thing is
in this culture we have been doing
education in a stupid way how's that for
an oxymoron so Anthony O'Neill is
leading the charge he's the tip of the
spear his book tour for debt-free degree
started today the book launched and is
available in bookstores today we are so
excited about this he started with an
appearance this morning on Fox & Friends
in New York City I'm holding the list of
the 70
appearances he'll be doing in the next
two weeks in my hands
he's guys going to be everywhere and
he's gonna be doing book signings and a
lot of these locations and around
America I hope you got in on the
pre-sale but if you didn't the book is
only 20 bucks debt-free degree how to
send your kid to college debt-free so
that you don't add to this national
problem but more importantly you don't
bring a curse to your own family of
teaching your kids the student loan
debts are the only way to get an
education it's absurd don't do that the
first book signing will be tomorrow in
Chicago Barnes and Noble 6:00 p.m. over
there in Skokie area old orchard center
and I will be giving away $500 that
could work towards your college fund if
you got a baby you could work a long way
towards your college fund getting things
started right no purchase necessary to
win the money you got to be 18 or older
of course all those state laws and
everything so here's the deal get in
touch with debt-free degree learn this
stuff this is the week by the way thank
you the borrowed future podcast about
the Student Loan debacle episode one
launched last Monday and it is already
in the top 10 in the Apple podcast so
pretty incredible they don't that's puts
us in the top 1% of all podcasts it's
actually beating this show when this
shows always up there right around the
top 20 top 10 I'm running like 15 or 16
today and it's running 10 so I'm beating
up on myself how smart is that but
anyway here we are
so borrowed future eight episodes
another one drops today the second
episode you can subscribe wherever you
get great podcasts this will blow your
mind this is not a ramsey personality
podcast it's the first time the rimsey
network has done something that's not
this is all about experts and some of us
are experts in this space so I'm quoted
Anthony's quoted so on Ken Coleman
different ones through the process so
download that podcast let's learn about
this stuff people let's change this you
want to go to school
that free were giving away $10,000 worth
of scholarships at Dave Ramsey not
comment on Anthony O'Neil dot-com rather
we've got 10,000 scholarships that you
can search through free at Anthony
O'Neill comm and none of them are a loan
hidden inside a scholarship boy the
skunky stuff some of you people are
doing to these kids out there you ought
to have your ears boxed it's
unbelievable
I'll come get the free grant and
scholarship and then when he signs up he
finds out it was a loan
you skunks you need to stop this stuff
man you stink it's bad you want to do
what your college that's going to cost
all the major colleges and most of the
minor ones are in our database we've got
a College calculator you can jump on at
Anthony O'Neill comm completely free
we're going to help you stop this this
is a series of decisions that we're
making that are dumb and they're based
on mythology and the mythology has to
stop one piece of mythology is all
education pays off no it doesn't if you
get a PhD in German polka history that's
not gonna pay off for you go 175
thousand dollars in debt and call me up
and tell me you can't get a job well no
duh dumb but you studied something that
doesn't work in the marketplace of
course it doesn't all pay off all
education is not valuable in the
marketplace you get these nuanced little
tiny degrees down in some little corner
of the world that to people do you know
we do dog archaeology what you're
kidding me canine archeology you got a
degree in that they make a degree in
that they don't I made that up but
goodness I mean people do this stuff and
then they go I can't find any money
that's doing canine archaeology and I
spent seventy four thousand get the
whole cultural ID to me no you were a
dumb byte and your parents were worse
they let you do it they ought to have
their ears boxed grab your kid by the
ears go don't get a degree in something
stupid it makes you look stupid you'd
have been better off just being stupid
not in debt don't do it don't do it get
a degree in something where you actually
learn something that you can actually
use in the marketplace and where you to
go to school nobody gives a rip where
you go to school unless you're hanging
around with a bunch of blue buds with
sunburn on their upper lip because their
nose is in the air
no one else gives a rip you went to
Harvard no one else now here in the real
world real people like me we don't care
all we care is can you do the work are
you dumber than a rock can you actually
get brain cells that rub together did
you learn something while you were
getting that degree I meet people who
are much more valuable in the
marketplace that did two years of
community college two years of the state
school worked their way through and paid
cash then some guy $240,000 in debt
because he was all concerned about where
he went to school because he thought
where he went to school is an indicator
of his future success that's a lie
there's absolutely no data out there
well the connections you make are with
other stupid broke people that's how you
make connections with that's the biggest
lie ever told where you went to school
matters for less than 1% of the jobs
it's a joke it's a joke don't overpay
for your education work can you tell
we're waging war around here we're tired
of the stupidity and we're tired of
people's lives being torn apart by it
get this is a book that free degree
it'll help you change your life